on y va maqbool que ça fait on ne peut
rien vous cacher monsieur baba hélas les
patrons en plus ils sont en réunion
c'est super ça va
[Applaudissements]
j'ai répondu dans son bouquet alors la
maison voilà vous êtes ou manteaux robes
originales et surtout mars
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une petite fille pas aux crues c'est
bien pour vous regardez up alors ce qui
est bien c'est que comme à des 8
on n'a pas trop trop de moyens tenez
patron eh bien on a du pain rassis donc
j'ai oublié de le casser comme ça je
vais vous faire un petit mélange voilà à
même le sol et il fait beau dit alors
qui veut placer la bessée ça va mais
chut
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]